S
CALLRESIDENTMPO UNPREPARED
TRADITL ALERAL.S. O  NATIONAL S.
SOURCES SAY CAL CONVINCED
FOOP DMTS,NCLUDINGMcMAST A JOHN
DENT WASED HE
PUR
PURSUED GOALS  RATHER
NATIONAL INTER
CARL BERNSTEIN JOINS
MORE ON THE DROPPING WTE THAT O
ABOMINATHEVEICANS W HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE CALLS RUSSIAN
ALMOST SLAVISHLY SEEKING PUN'
AP TO PRO H
UP, AS A GREATDEME PREDECESSORSI
THEM INCOMPETENT, NOW THAT
TR WAS THERE THEY COULD DEAL.
OVERALL TENOR OF
SPECIFICS OF THEM SHOW
THE PRESIDE OF UNITED
STATES IN TERMS ALLIES
BUNGOSTSAST
ON T CAAIMERKEL AND THE
PRIME MINISTER OF GREAT BRITAIN,
THOSEALLS WOMEN AREBE SIS
TERMS BYES.
APO THEY HERE THE UNITED  C CLSE
WHAT WE HAVE PRESIDENT
VERY MUCH LIKE SS SAIDN BRIEFINS
BE ATTACKING PEOPLE, ALLT HIMSE.
DLE THEMO BASICATHEE U E
HANDLE C
>> AND IT IS CONSISTENT WITHVIO
THIS PRESIDENCY.
YO R THA TUR
ENJOYS ANIRECT LINE TODENT
P LEAST ERD
>>UST CALL THE HE CALL TRU
ESE GET  DID S
AN SHOULD BE
PUT THROUGH, COULD THESISTER NA
ESIDENCIES, HE IS BRIEFED BY
AIDES,NHEN
HE IS TALKING TO LEA SUREUP,IT E
THAT'S O OF THE PROBLEESCIRDOGAN
IN THA RUSSIANS HAVEUAL CLS T PF
THEY WERE EVERHEARD,LDWOUL GREAA
TO ANYONE WHOM. INS,
THOUGHT BYAIDES THAT SOMEHOWKIS
SECURI SERVICES HAD FOUNDT'S HEO
HIM, AND OFE T  TOLDN
ALMOLSREISCUSS
WITHHE UNITED STATES PULLING
FORCES OUT OF SYRIA ATGI SETTIN
SITUNITH OURAL T
KU ARAQ ANDN SYRIA WOUL AN WHOB
HISTICSTORIC ANIMOSITY BETWEEN
GAWATORE INSYRIA,
PARTLY ON THESE PHONE LL
ERDOGAN.
>> CA PRESIDENT WASN'T
ALWAYS DEFERENTAN IMPORTANT PAR.
YOU WRITE  CALLS
FEMALE LEA W SADISTIC, QUOTE, N
AK GERMANREL SHE STUPID. THEN TE
WAS REAIFCU HDL CALL, AND IN  T
PUT FORTH IN
WAS INTENDED.
IT WAS INTENDED TO HER UPUSE TH
WE SAME THAT HE
WANTED.HE AK
ELESS,ND ALSO THE
QUESTI OF CLOSESTGER SHAREF O D
PREOCCUPIED THE P
WITH ION, RTAINL SHARE
PROBABLY SHOULD BE PAIDY
ALLIES, BUT IN THESE CIS TITH T
CL THERE
IN SUCH VICIOU EXCLUSION THE MOH
RIGHTS
QUESTIONS,  THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO THE ALLIES  INSTEA.
AN WBOY AS SOMEBODY PUT,
ES T WOMEN.HE WAS ABUSIVE TO THO
WOMENESE CALLS.
>> IT